the Joe Rogan experience we could talk
about Tony Ferguson
what's this Saturday what about that
that's great got any questions he's been
working with them [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude he's he's sharper stronger and in
the best shape of his life it's the same
Tony that you know you think like it's
it gonna be the same Tony after you know
that you know he had he had some you
know family stuff go on is that gonna
change him
you know his opponents hope it changes
him but he is he's the same Tony when it
comes to fighting we don't get into
personal stuff we just stick to fighting
and the strategy he's sharper than ever
it's I'm not you know you can't
guarantee any wins but I will guarantee
that he's gonna go in a hundred percent
Tony
it's a crazy matchup it's very good
match that's like Russian Roulette right
there dude they're gonna be throwing
bombs at each other it's real good
particularly now with Donald has been on
a tear like the last four fights three
four fights I mean he's just looked so
good man al Iaquinta fight for people
who know how good al is for Donald to
handle al like that and drop him and you
know and really put it to him like the
way I'll put it I mean al said he beat
the [ __ ] out of me
that's what Al's exact quote was I was
very complimentary and respectful after
the fight yeah cowboy is no joke that
guy's on fire he's not he doesn't fight
like a beep he doesn't fight like Connor
he fights like Tony so it's like
similarly it's like towing versus Tony
you know what I mean yeah and it's [ __ ]
do you both get on the ground they're
very good on the ground
we respect Cowboys [ __ ] ground game a
lot and you know we you know we do what
we could to make sure you know nothing
bad happens on the ground you know what
I mean yeah
but they both have everything they both
have great strike and they both have
great submissions Tony's coming for war
like he always does it's gonna be the
same told ya throwing down that's for
sure did now went on let me ask you this
because you know the answer to this when
Tony had his knee fixed
did he spar during that camp because
someone said that he didn't do any spine
it was like one of the rumors from
someone who knew him I think he keeps
his sparring you know turning my
striking right yes
I'm never there for the strike you know
I've never it's separate we don't know
I'm never I've never seen him I'm never
there for the strike the show us when
there's grapple his the the amount of
time that it took him and Jake in Big
Bear he didn't we didn't bring anybody
to spar like hardcore
it was just like lights touching because
the night letting me heal oh no that's a
different fight I'm talking about the
knee remember you having the massive
knee injury and then he had surgery and
then what I heard knows you're right
during the past fight oh yeah
no spark no spark yeah that's crazy very
light very light mmm well I guess you
know when you already world class you
could do that and he put that knee he
didn't want to [ __ ] that wanted to make
sure nothing went wrong get to get to
the flight it was it was the right
choice
sure and when he showed up against
Pettis he looked like same ol Tony he
did it was stunning vicious you're
talking about a catastrophic knee injury
and then six months later
yes fighting a world-class fighter and
he's gained his legs checked yeah you
know he got the me checked even worried
at one point in time that he might be
injured what makes Tony so good in my
opinion just based on working with them
is it seems that uh
you know at the highest level high
pressure fight people are aren't as
they're more cautious they don't want to
try do anything stupid they're not just
letting it swing and letting it go Tony
isn't like that Tony is people want to
get to the point where they just unleash
and they don't give a [ __ ] and there's a
lot of fighters like that but Tony when
he's in there it's like like Nick Diaz
they're not afraid to throw anything you
know what I mean he goes in there he'll
throw two spinning elbows in a row and
he's just having fun
it's like he's alive and he's having fun
in there and he's and on the ground he's
not gonna be hesitant to do something
wild and crazy hmm that's just the way
he is man and he thrives in the cage and
there's zero hold back he's he's and he
comes out guns a-blazing the hold
yeah they're both at the top of their
game man that's for sure you know and
Tony didn't miss a step when he got that
knee injury which is very impressive
even as striking was on point when he
fought Pettis yeah and even got tested
he got clipped and Pettis heard him you
know he knows how to survive man he's a
very unusual fighter man very difficult
to prepare for always studying
oh he's adding new weapons to his
arsenal always adding something to his
workout routine he's always adding [ __ ]
he has the ability to focus more than
anybody I know
his ability to focus and you see that
not only in you know the striking aspect
of his game or the wrestling but you see
it in the jiu-jitsu and that's where I
see it is he has so much focus he
doesn't I don't have to reteach him [ __ ]
I will show him very complicated
transition of moves like to you know in
spiderweb doing the bollinger break
there's like four moves you got to do
pop you got to fire him it's got to be
so smooth there can't be any fuck-ups
and I show him this and after like four
or five reps he's got it down hmm and
most people it take its take six months
to get it down to understand it and he
just can he just uh doesn't take him
long to learn [ __ ] anything wrestling
striking anything new he's down but he
doesn't forget it
that's the most important thing he
remembers all the [ __ ] and um you know
it's so who's working with him with
striking a guy named Rashad used to I
think he was like an Olympic hopeful
back in the day
boxer yeah most guys do that right yeah
it seems like there's not a lot of guys
who just used one for all striking yeah
he's got a bunch of people to train him
he's got a couple different strength and
conditioning coaches he's got a whole
crew I think that's important he's
really into recovery like he spends a
little serious time recovering he's got
all these contraptions you know those
things that you could there like leg
sleeve i'ma text and and they inflate
mm-hm and he's on that all the time he's
when it comes to rehab for any injury
he's like like a professional NFL player
you know
and ice baths like you know at massages
he doesn't [ __ ] around man he's he's a
hundred percent thinking about and doing
something for the fight
usually just non-stop he can go on for
hours it's crazy